I'm Seth Rogen I like to be chubby and
it's funny I like to eat Carl's jr.
shirtless today because there's a lot of
shirtless gags in this movie huh it's a
gag neighbors this movie is pretty
[ __ ] funny it's a comedy
so what counts most are you gonna laugh
hell's to the yes just thinking about
some jokes cracks me the [ __ ] up Oh
comedies the directing and editing of
this film is pretty [ __ ] solid I
bring up all those categories because
there's a lot of improv in this movie
I'm sure of it and you need a good
editor for [ __ ] like that the script is
also pretty good it has really good
character surprisingly and the
characters are honored by this awesome
[ __ ] cast Seth Rogen as McDonald's
once again Seth Rogen [ __ ] hilarious
he's always funny even these shitty
movies except for you me into pretty no
one was funny in that movie it's great
to see him in a movie where he plays
like a totally believable husband and
father and he still says Rogen he's got
that likeable chubby thing going on but
importantly does he make you laugh
hell's to the yeah but to me the real
star of this movie was rose [ __ ] burn
the day I have sex with Rose Byrne it's
gonna burn because I have yes she is
beautiful absolutely but she's not just
that she's also a very talented actress
it's great to see her back into comedy
where she really gets let her
personality shine every time she was on
screen I was captain [ __ ] hooked her
comedic chops the character ability she
has you see her breasts at one point in
this movie I mean it's all being in [ __ ]
but whatever so put my penis in between
those things you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah okay she commits to the bits
in this film 100% absolutely perfect in
this movie at high school musical
sensation Zac Efron is the president of
the fraternity honestly dude I think
this movie is gonna get him a lot of
respect that might sound weird based off
the role it's such a different image
compared to what people usually have
like oh he's just pretty he's good good
I don't care why people still use that
as an insult he's good he's happy having
sex with men I don't know this dude he
cracked me up quite a good amount of
times he's totally believable as his
character and god damn does he have a
hot-ass body I'm not gay
well maybe but I was looking at his body
going that shit's hot I mean it's no
Ryan but whatever and that should give
him real character in this film you see
that he's a guy who doesn't really
believe in his future and that all he
has is this frat goddamn dead body man
that body had suck those nipples James
Franco's brother dave Franco as the vice
president of the frat I think he's
getting to a point where we don't know
him as James Franco's brother he might
not have been able to show us the
dramatic abilities he has yet as far as
comedies go he gets better every [ __ ]
movie he is funny in this film and he
has more of you know sincere character
thing going on in this film where he
actually is smart don't like Zac Efron's
character and at one point you see this
guy's ass here's a nice ass I'd [ __ ]
that ass been regretting even I
Barinholtz as Jimmy I know what you're
thinking who the [ __ ] is this guy I
don't know all I know is he's a funny
[ __ ] he has one of those faces
that's like he looks familiar but I
don't remember what movie is him and
he's got some pretty racy jokes
he says the n-word like two times in
this film and rare does a white guy pull
off an n-word and actually he's funny
I mean although Django Unchained was
hilarious because of that damn word yeah
this dude keep a lookout for him he's
really good Christopher mintz-plasse he
is the best role in this movie by far
most of the movie actually focuses on
him great character journey totally
kidding don't know why they cast him
kind of in the film throughout doesn't
really have that many lines this guy's
career going downhill or something cuz
he's way more talented than the [ __ ]
roll they gave him in this literally
anybody gonna play this guy cheri gonna
play this guy that's an insult Jerry
this film is HIGHlarious the comedy
never stops and that's just enough
heartfelt moments and thank god we've
gotten a good comedy because we needed
one for a while now let me get straight
to the point here oh and all I gotta say
got it Ryan right thanks for checking
out my review for neighbors why don't
you go ahead scroll that comment box
below and tell me if your neighbors
pissed you off what would you do if you
want to see more episodes straight to
the point click that [ __ ] last but not
least if you wanna get updated every
time one of my reviews or videos is out
code including this but if I might dig
to subscribe that's right
the dick Lehr doesn't about this little
Mac he has [ __ ] all of his neighbors
and they all are pregnant I have a lot
of child support that's why I need a
blow-up on YouTube I'm gonna go [ __ ]
another neighbor right now Marie